fans of both the Hunger Games franchise
and maybe even new fans to the franchise
why should they experience this film in
IMAX well I think you know the the large
format which I'm such a huge fan of is
just the most immersive way of seeing
really any kind of movie sure it makes
it more immersive when you're in the
arena or when you're in certain
sequences and certain environments and
things like that but what I really love
is also just the detail that you get to
see and that you get to pick up when
you're seeing in for L format and not
just the sort of the detail of the
environments but also the detail and the
subtleties of performance you know we
have fantastic actors in this and you
know it's just kind of Shame when you
hear people are like looking at these
things on their phones or iPads or
computers and things like that when you
can see it in an environment like this
and see their faces you know that large
and really get every little Nuance of
the performance I think it's just
fantastic